thursday night football san francisco
49ers hosting the green bay packers
there
is the long list of guys who will not be
available
for the home team crap injuries the
covet 19
positive kendrick bourne and then the
high risk
close contact protocol that has knocked
out brandon iuke
and trent williams just an amazing array
of talent that will not be available to
the 49ers
but hey they're going to play the game
and the packers have injury issues as
well and covet issues aj dillon
on the list jamal williams one of the
close contacts he's not available
aaron jones with the calf injury he's
questionable he made the trip i saw that
mike garofalo of nfl media
said there is not optimism at this point
that jones will be able to go
with that calf strain they shouldn't
play him they shouldn't
they just don't it's okay don't risk
bringing him back on a thursday when
he's not 100
when he's you're running back and he's
definitely one of the best players on
your team
and you know the 49ers are you know
in strugglesville right now this to me
would be the game where i'd go you know
what tyler irvin
uh i'm blanking out on the other running
back that's on the roster that's there
i would just go this is what we're going
to do if we can't beat this damn team
with all these players out without aaron
jones
then we're not for real anyways and i
just wouldn't risk it to have them lose
them you know another three weeks or so
to play tonight yeah they actually
didn't have another tail back other than
irvin but they had a guy in the practice
squad
so they were going to break up right
that i assume has been brought up
dexter williams from notre dame that's
who it was right and i think i think
that's what i read yesterday that he was
going to be in the rotation
with with irvin so we'll see but i
wouldn't risk it
playing aaron jones again i just i think
that's that's a tough injury
especially for a running back when they
plant that foot in the ground and
hey they're a team that's they got their
eyes on the super bowl keep the eye on
the prize don't you know don't make it
all about this week and right now this
second
all right pft props time odds provided
by points bet
sports book the official sports betting
partner of nbc sports and
let's start with the assumption that
nick mullins will be the starting
quarterback
for the 49ers will he throw an
interception which is another way of
saying over under on interceptions for
mullins 0.5
yeah i'm gonna say he throws an
interception yes i i am
you know i just i know they'll rely
heavily on the run game
but the way he played last time
all the injuries they have i just don't
think they're going to be able to sit
there and just rely on the run game all
game long at some point he's going to
have to throw the football a little bit
and man who the hell is he going to
throw to so that's where
just i just go yes he's going to throw
an interception at some point during
this game
and and let's make it even more
interesting right over under
0.5 on interceptions thrown by nick
mullins
to a packers player when there's no 49er
receiver within 10 yards
over under i hope we got past that
hopefully he's learned that in the
meantime
since the eagles football game right so
i mean liz listen i'll i'll ask you
i i'm i'm truly intrigued you know i
really am
i don't know and of course i'm not in
the building i haven't talked to kyle
shanahan in forever
i don't see the practices i don't know
that but i don't know if i'd have the
guts to start nick mullins tonight if i
was the head coach of the team that's
just
you know and again like we said like i
said we don't see it but
how what's like what's your gut say
about that well people assume it's
mullins because mullins came in for
garoppolo
last week but kyle shanahan explained a
few weeks back
that once garoppolo was healthy they
were going to make the decision
each week between mullins and beathard
based on the game plan and the match
up not based on how the guys were
performing and he specifically said
he doesn't want them to think there's a
competition each week at practice
he doesn't want that extra stress on
them this is about
match-ups and game plan so the fact that
mullins came in doesn't mean that kyle
shanahan currently has mullins ahead of
beathard on the depth chart so i mean
we'll just see
look mullins was horrible beathard
really didn't get a chance to play all
that much before garoppolo came back
so i'd be more inclined
to give beathard a shot but i'd be i'd
be ready and willing to go to mullins
and frankly if they're that
interchangeable
i'd get them both ready and maybe use
them both that may be my
edge here to the extent that the packers
uh aren't fully ready for either guy
make him deal with either guy yeah i
mean him deal with both guys
i wouldn't be shocked if you saw both
tonight i wouldn't i would be leaning
towards cj beatler too
just just from this aspect you know like
yeah we saw mullins last week i would
think we saw
mullins because he was the backup and i
bet you they thought they were going to
have a little more success running
and then the boot game and things like
that a movement
were going to be more of play and that's
why mullins is the backup
bethard has more of an ability to make
plays with his arm as a drop back passer
and man with these injuries and the
running back issues and everything like
that
i just can't imagine that the run game
bootleg game is going to be able to
carry them that way to where they're
gonna have to make some plays in the
drop back pass game
and to me just you know again in the
limit as we've seen i think cj beathard
has a more explosive arm
and is a little more more capable of
making things happen that way to where
he might give them an advantage tonight
i'll be
i'll be interested in where shanahan
goes with this one
let's flip it over to green bay packers
aaron rodgers over under on the passing
yards 300 and remember
no aaron jones quite possibly no jamal
williams no aj dillon tyler erlin
tyler irvin excuse me and dexter
williams the options at tailback they
may have to throw it a lot over under
300 gosh
i you know they're not a team the 49ers
they're not easy to throw the ball on
um but i i think i'm gonna have to
i don't know what i'm gonna do here i
think i'm gonna have to go for over 300
tonight
i i don't feel real comfortable about
that but the one thing i would hope that
green bay
takes away from watching seattle from
verse san francisco last week
more than anything is just going wait
you know we don't always have to make
things so complicated a lot of the times
it ends up man-to-man on the outside
versus
their receivers it's either 3-d zone or
man-to-man and last week
russell wilson and company just went no
wait our guy out there is better than
your guy
and we're just gonna me and him one on
one we're just gonna beat you up that
way
and i i don't know why rogers and
davonte adams wouldn't do the same thing
tonight
now the 49ers don't give up a ton of big
plays that's where i'm a little
hesitant but without maybe an aaron
jones
i think the 49ers will be all over the
run game i'm going to go with rogers
there but
uh i don't feel terribly comfortable
with that i think it's more realistic he
can run a 280 270 type game
so i don't disagree with that yeah i
think i could see more devonta adams
right devonte adams most receiving yards
for him
or the field for the green bay packers i
have a feeling this is an easy one for
you
i i i yeah i'm gonna i want to go
him over anyone in the game anyone
i think that's the thing yeah yeah well
there's nobody
it still doesn't there's nobody that's
gonna challenge him there um
yeah i'm gonna go with devonte adams
here you know the only way i see it and
the 49ers aren't really one of these
type of teams where they double people
and do all that you know maybe this is a
week they do it without aaron jones in
the game and they realize wow
devonta adams is the guy and we're not
sure who the hell else is the guy
because that's a rotating door in a
weekly basis
but i'm still going to go with him
because they feature him and they always
got creative ways to get him the ball
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports